I believe that a million dollars of our
revenue is because I personally am a New
York Jets fan the best way to create
demand in today's world is to create as
much social media content as you humanly
can around what you know you know don't
fake it till you make it talk about what
you know how you know it what you're
seeing and then bring your personal life
into it whether that's golf immediately
four people in the chat talked about my
Aaron Rodgers t-shirt and my jet stand
up I'm going to say this very clear
vaynermedia which is now probably like a
350 million dollar a year Revenue
business I believe that a million
dollars of our revenue is I personally
am a New York Jets fan that there is a
CMO marketer out there that feels a
closeness to me because in our both of
our sadness of our Jets fandom and
subconsciously she or he has given us
business without even realizing it and
that's how the world actually works